Thanks Sarah.
So I don't want to include the easy mode of my game in master, since I
still want the official version of the game to be the standard difficulty.
But I do want to include all the latest changes from master in
the easy mode branch.
Do to this, I'll first check out the easy mode branch.
So that easy-mode will update whenever I make changes.
Then I run git merge master easy-mode.
Now git alerts me there was a marge conflict in game.js.
This means that both branches, master and
easy-mode changed the same part of game.js.
Just like when Rachel and Jake both modified the same line.
Git can't know which changes to keep.
So I'll have to resolve the conflicts.
To resolve the conflict, I need to open game.js and
find where the conflict occurred.
Now git represents conflicts using these special lines, so
I can always find it by searching for a bunch of less than signs in a row.
If I scroll down,
I can see that these lines divides the screen into three sections.
One, two, three.
The top section, marked HEAD is my code.
The bottom section, marked master is the code that's in master right now.
And the middle section is the original version that both branches modified,
which git called the common ancestor.
Now when I'm trying to resolve a merge conflict,
the first thing I do is try to understand what changes both branches have made.
The difference between the middle section and
the top, shows the changes that I made in the easy-mode branch.
If I'd forgotten what those changes were, I can spend a few minutes
comparing and recall that the difference was changing this three to a two.
The difference between the middle and
the bottom shows the changes that were made in master.
And it happens that this particular change was made by Sarah.
It's pretty common when I'm resolving merge conflicts.
That one set of changes will be made by me.
And the other by someone else.
So, I might need to go talk to that person.
But first, I always try to understand what they were doing.
By looking at the changes they made.
Here, it looks like Sarah replaced this entire section of
code with a call to a function called breakIntoFragments.
Now that probably means that she created this function and
moved this code into that function.
Which is a pretty common way to make code more readable by breaking it
up into understandable parts.
Now, I need to find this function that she wrote to see if
she just moved the code over or if she also changed something.
I could search for it.
But in this case, it turns out that it's right up here.
Now it might look like this function existed in both versions.
Since it's not inside the special merge conflict lines.
But actually, that's just because this change didn't create a conflict.
Now after I've spent a few minutes comparing this function to the code that was
removed by Sarah below.
I could see that she didn't make any changes to the code, other than to move it.
Now, how should I reserve this merge conflict?
On the next screen,
rewrite the code to what you think the final version should be.
Make sure to remove all of these special lines.
For example, if I wanted to undo my changes, I could just delete my version and
the original version, as well as these special lines to leave only Sarah's code.
Instead, you should create a version of the code that incorporates both
of our changes